hi everyone my name is Adam Koch
illowsky with IBM cloud and I'm here to
talk to you today about data leaks what
they are how you use one and the kind of
things you ought to be thinking about as
you set one up to power your
applications and sort of create more
intelligent experiences for your users
so data leaks exists because we're all
you know awash with data and we've got
systems of record
we've got systems of engagement we've
got streaming data we've got batch data
internal external data and it's really a
combination of these different kinds of
data sources that leads us to get
powerful insights about you know what
our users are doing about the way the
world is working around us and you know
leads us to develop more intelligent
applications data lakes start by
collecting all those different types of
data sources through a common ingestion
framework and that ingestion framework
is something that typically wants to be
able to support a diverse array of
different types of data and it wants to
kind of standardize and centralize all
that stuff into a common storage
repository that's not always required
but typically you don't want to be
analyzing the source data directly you
want to be able to take a copy of it so
that you've got the flexibility to do
the kind of things you need to do with
that data and speaking of that the data
typically doesn't come in a form where
you can use it right out of the box
there's a lot of you know data cleansing
and data preparation that's required
right there is often times the ability
to or the requirement to create new
features something we call feature
extraction combinations of different
types of data that need to be pulled
together in order to create the right
sort of bits of information to analyze
right
and once you sort of cleanse that data
prepped the data model the right kind of
features for your analysis then you get
to the fun part which is actually going
in and doing the machine learning model
training and doing your advanced
analytics and each of these steps is
typically creating new derived data
sources you know data sets that tie back
to the original one right and that
relationship is a really important thing
to capture because let's say there was a
problem with one of your data sources
you know there was a correction that
needed to be made you need to understand
how that flow
through the entire pipeline of more
refined datasets and models that you're
producing so that you can go back and
correct it and that's where this
governance stuff comes into play this is
something that's really you know infused
at every step of the journey
it means collecting metadata you know
data about your data you know the right
kinds of information about the tables in
your data sets and how they relate to
one another and it means being able to
enforce policies so that as an
organization we use the data the way
it's meant to be used the way it's
intended to be used the way it's
acceptable to be used to drive the
business forward so it's really
something that can't be bolted on after
the fact it's something that has to be
present throughout the entire lifecycle
and if we stopped here we haven't really
changed anything right it's only by
getting these insights that we're
producing in this data Lake back out
into the real world that we're able to
you know deliver on the business promise
of these data lakes that we're all
investing in and that's where this app
you know the apply step comes in and
this can take a few different forms
right you might be you know building
simply dashboards that are helping you
know business executives make smarter
decisions about where to take the
business forward about you know sort of
new projects to invest in or you might
be building smarter applications that
are able to make you know intelligent
recommendations to the users of those
apps based on you know historical
purchase data and increasingly we're
also seeing a lot of process automation
where you know an intelligent model can
smooth over some typically manual
business processes and create a more
intelligent experience and end based on
you know this sort of rich data driven
understanding of the problem at hand and
you know really this whole process
iterates back right those more
intelligent applications they end up
generating new data and the cycle
continues and so that in a nutshell at
very high level is what a data lake does
some of you may have heard us talk about
the latter to AI the AI ladder
and when we talk about that we talk
about collecting data we talk about
organizing data we talk about analyzing
and we talk about infusing and really
those four steps on this ladder are
things that you can see represented
throughout this data Lake environment
right clearly over here we're doing a
lot of collection of these individual
sources of data this data preparation
and feature extraction step in a govern
fashion is absolutely what we mean by
the organizing of data ml model training
is a key example of data analysis and
when we talk about infusing you know the
insights from the data Lake into
applications that's really this last
step here and so there's very very much
a clear linkage between you know
climbing this AI ladder and a data Lake
you know as a vehicle that can help you
you know make that journey if you
enjoyed this content please consider
liking or subscribing thank you